في صحيفه الجارديان مقال يعتبر اثاره قضيه
الاباده الجماعيه ضد اسرائيل بمنزله دعوه
لاستيقاظ العديد من الحكومات الغربيه
ووسائل الاعلام التي دعمت ما سماها الحرب
الاسرائيليه الوحشيه من خلال تواطؤها
ومحاوله توجيه النقاش بشان حقيقه ما يحصل
في غزه ودعم اسرائيل دبلوماسيا وتزويدها
بالاسلحه ومن صحيفتها ارت مقال خلص الى ان
سلسله الاخفاقات الامنيه تعني ان سياسه
الردع التي تبنتها اسرائيل في السابق لم
تعد مجديه الان منبها الى ان الحل الوحيد
للمشكلات الامنيه يتمثل في اتفاق سلام وحل
الدولتين وقياده سياسيه تخفف العبء على
الجيش عدا ذلك لن تحقق اسرائيل الامن الذي
تتطلع اليه مهما بلغت قوتها
العسكريه النيويورك تايمز نشرت تقريرا
يبرز تحليلات خبراء يرون ان الضربات التي
نفذت ضد الحوثيين في اليمن من غير المرجح
ان تردعهم مستبعدين فرضيه وقف الجماعه
هجماتها ضد السفن في البحر الاحمر حسب
التقرير تمكن الحوثيون من تعزيز قدراتهم
العسكريه خلال السنوات الماضيه يقول احد
المحللين انهم لن يترددوا في
التصعيد الفاينانشال تايمز كتبت ان
الضربات التي قادتها الولايات المتحده
بريطانيا في اليمن تثير مخاوف من توسيع
الصراع في المنطقه لافته الى ان هجمات
الحوثيين المستمره في البحر الاحمر اجبرت
البيت الابيض على اعاده حساباته على الرغم
من محاولات بايدن التحكم في نطاق الحرب في
غزه صحيفه لوموند لاحظت ان عمليه حارس
الازدهار التي اطلقت بضغط من الولايات
المتحده لتامين سفن الشحن لم تحضى بدعم
كبير من الغرب وع ذلك الفشل في حشد
تعزيزات دفاعيه لانجاح المهمه ترى الصحيفه
ان تردد الدول الغربيه وفي مقدمتها
الاوروبيه ساهم في عزله الولايات المتحده
في
[موسيقى]
المنطقه